how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
last night we had the season
two finale of the mandalorian and it did
not
disappoint in the slightest and not only
was the season finale just an
amazing episode but it probably
contained some of the best star wars
scenes period
there's ever been so we're gonna break
down everything that happened in this
final episode
so if you have not seen the season two
finale of the mandalorian and
you are trying to avoid all spoilers
this is your chance to click away
but if you've seen it or you simply
don't care about spoilers let's begin
the opening scene starts out with boba
taking out the t41 that dr pershing is
on
from there den and cara board the ship
the pilot ends up holding dr pershing
hostage
after shooting his own comrade we find
out that kara actually has a pretty big
backstory as the pilot mentions alderaan
kara lost somebody dear to her on
alderaan and we learned that the pilot
was on the death star at one point in
time but got off
but clearly lost some friends and
possibly family when the death star blew
up
kara shoots him in the face and we end
up finding out that dr pershing is a
clone scientist which we kind of already
knew because of the badge
they then head out to find bokatan and
reeves and as they land
we can see boca tan ship the gauntlet as
it's docked the same
exact ship she had from the clone wars
they end up finding beau and kosuka and
they asked for their help
but things get really heated between
boba bo and kosuka because there is a
long history here
after hearing boba's voice beau says
you're not a mandalorian
you are disgraced to that armor in which
bobo replies that it was his father's
then beau says don't you mean your
donors now for those of you who may not
know
boba is in fact a clone a clone of jango
fett
however boba is different from every
other clone that was ever created
you see boba was an unaltered clone
which means that it didn't age super
quickly like all of the other clones but
for the most part was a normal child
jango specifically made one clone to be
this way so he could raise him as his
son
and that's what he did boba was a son to
django and jango was boba's father
now the history goes a little bit
further back than these taunts right
here that we see in the episode
now boba's armor comes from his father
django and jango's armor comes from his
father he was once the true leader of
mandalore now jango fett had a mentor
jaster mariel
when the civil war broke out on
mandalore jaster was killed by toravizla
of the opposing faction
the war finally ended when jango ended
up killing tor
so boba is the son of the true
mandalorian
now of course we know that jango fett
would ultimately go on to get killed by
mace windu
so it's kind of a good thing that boba
took off during this before the end when
luke skywalker showed up because he
doesn't exactly have good feelings
toward the jedi
but bo katan during the clone wars was a
part of the death watch faction
the opposing faction of django and the
faction that killed
jester muriel so there was already
pretty high tension between bo katan and
boba fett
and since boba is one of the millions of
clones of jango
bo and koshka recognize his voice and
realize that he is a clone which is why
she says it's a disgrace for him to wear
that armor
now eventually they stopped fighting
realizing that this is why their planet
got torn apart in the first place by the
civil war
and ultimately decide to help bogatan
decides to help if she can get the dark
saber from moth
because whoever holds the darksaber gets
to rule mandalore
and as we've learned the people have
been exiled by the empire from going
back to mandalore and they decide that
it's time to take back their world
which is why they need the darksaber
from here they form a plan to board moff
ship
using the help of dr pershing who we
find out isn't necessarily evil
since he never really wanted to kill the
child in the first place but is merely a
scientist that is kind of being held
captive by the empire
but he doesn't really have a loyalty to
the empire and he doesn't want the child
to die which is why he's helping
the doctor informs them of the dark
troopers who they met before because
they're the ones who took baby yoda but
they figure out a plan to get past the
dark troopers and they put on a little
ruse to get on board the ship
boba acts like he's trying to take down
the ship and once the ship docks
heads off into jump space now the whole
entire time this is happening
moff gideon clearly realizes that this
is a trick he doesn't want them to dock
in the first place and deploys tie
fighters to keep them away
but they get on board anyways now mando
makes it right to the dark troopers just
in the nick of time only one manages to
get out and he puts up a heck of a fight
against him
luckily he has the best scar spear which
will definitely come in handy in just a
bit
bo kara finnick and koshka completely
devour everybody in their path as they
make their way to the bridge this was a
truly awesome scene to see
but of course moff is not there because
he knew this was a trick the entire time
instead he went to find baby yoda and is
with him in the cell when mando shows up
moff is holding the darksaber over
grogu they talk and eventually come to
an agreement
mando just wants the child and moff just
wants to keep the darksaber
so they make an agreement mando gets to
take the child and
moff gets to keep the darksaber mando
does not care about the darksaber as
we've learned
he told beau that she could have it he
doesn't really care about ruling
mandalore
and of course at this point he just
wants grogu back but of course it's a
trick by moth
when mando goes to get the child he
attacks him with the darksaber but
fortunately the only thing that the
darksaber can't cut through
is bheskar which of course is what his
entire armor is made out of
and his spear is pure besgar which leads
us to a very epic fight between moff and
mando
eventually den manages to defeat him he
takes the darksaber and moff and he
heads to the helm to join the others
and this is where things get a little
bit complicated and we actually have a
little bit of unresolved issues
now when den enters the helm holding the
darksaber in his hand
along with maf gideon in the other we
can see a very troubled look on bokeh
tan
and this is because she knows that mando
beat moff in hand-to-hand combat
claiming the darksaber from him which
means that she knows she will now have
to fight den
in hand-to-hand combat and win the
darksaber from him
we find this out when we hear about the
rules of the darksaber and ruling
mandalore
you must defeat the wielder of the
darksaber in hand-to-hand combat and win
it from them
so now the only way that bokutan can get
the darksaber is to defeat mando in
combat
however mando again doesn't really care
he doesn't want to rule mandalore he
only wanted grosgu
so he offers it up freely he says i
yield it's yours
but she can't accept it she wants it
done the right way she wants to be the
rightful ruler
now this is where it ends and we don't
get a resolution as the dark troopers
return
mando ejected the dart troopers out into
space and the force of the ejection
pushed them really far back
but they have thrusters and they are
able to fly back once the momentum of
them being ejected wears off so they
board the light cruiser
form back in order and go to attack them
moff gideon laughs as he knows that
there's no way that they're going to be
able to defeat the dark troopers
there's around 40 to 50 dark troopers
and blasters can't penetrate their armor
they're basically useless against them
mando alone could barely defeat one of
them now he's dealing with 50.
moff laughs he knows he's won den
beau and the others seem to know that
they can't take them on either
it seems like moff has won until a
reading is picked up
and we see one single x-wing show up
as the x-wing shows up we all of a
sudden see grogu reacting to something
he of course senses the pilot of the
x-wing
and he senses the force kara jokes and
says
one x-wing were saved but as it turns
out
even though she was joking she was right
as that one x-wing was piloted
by luke skywalker we see a cloaked
figure
board the ship armed with a green
lightsaber and a glove
over the hand moving very much like luke
skywalker
he walks through the dark troopers like
they are nothing
literally walks through he isn't running
he isn't shuffling to try and not get
hit
he is literally walking through these
dark troopers they are nothing to a jedi
master which he now is using a
combination of lightsaber techniques and
the force
he makes his way up the elevator to the
final batch of dark troopers
we then get a scene that is very much a
mirror scene of the darth vader
rogue one scene arguably the best darth
vader scene of all time
and now his son luke skywalker gets the
same scene
in true epic fashion again using the
force and a lightsaber he walks through
them
and makes his way to the blast door moth
realizing that it's luke skywalker that
has come tries to kill himself
but cara stops him then of course
realizing that it's a jedi who has come
for grosgr
then tells them to open the door he
enters takes off his hood
and it's luke skywalker then asks are
you a jedi in which he responds
yes luke reaches for the child it is now
time for grogu to go with luke and learn
the ways of the force
and the jedi grogu is hesitant and den
can see this
he tells luke he doesn't want to go with
you but luke explains that grogu
actually does want to go with him
but he wants mando's permission because
he loves him he's grown attached to him
he doesn't want to leave but he knows
that he has to
he picks up grogu and promises him that
he'll see him again
grosgu reaches out and touches den's
helmet in which
den removes his helmet this is another
mirror scene from episode 6
when vader takes off his helmet so he
can see his son luke
with his own eyes we see how emotional
it is for den to let groku go
groggu has basically become his son but
he tells him
not to be afraid he places him down and
grogu wraps his arms around his leg
before ultimately going to luke
and r2d2 an interaction between r2d2 and
grogu make it seem like they actually
know each other
and perhaps they did before groggu was
taken or r2d2 could simply recognize
that he's the same species as yoda
luke being the jedi who connected with
grogu when he reached out with the force
on the seeing stone
is there to take grogu away to train him
in the ways of the force and the jedi
he picks him up leaves and we see a very
emotional
den and that is the end of the season
until we get to a
post credit scene we are back on
tatooine in jabba's palace where we see
bit fortuna
on jabba's throne he was jabba's
right-hand man but unfortunately meets
his demise
when finnek and boba show up boba then
sits on the throne and we get an
announcement
that a boba fett series is coming
christmas 2021
titled the book of boba fett and it's
interesting that they didn't announce
that at disney's investors day when they
announced basically everything but
saving it for a really cool post-credits
scene makes a lot of sense as well and
i'm glad they did
so there's the season two finale
breakdown of the mandalorian
how did you feel when luke skywalker
showed up at the end
and do you think grogu and mando are
going to reunite in season three
or do you think that he might run into
kylo ren at one point in time since kylo
was also
one of the students of luke let me know
all your thoughts and feelings in the
comments down below
don't forget to subscribe for more
awesome content for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof
bye